all righty then welcome it is time for
drew's news we cast out our line
and we reel in that good old news tuna
uh-huh catch a keeper
and with me at the desk is my chicken of
the sea ross matthews
first up i found this story to be a
total delight our favorite girl dakota
johnson that's right her and i do the
little yellow book
and um her company tea time we curate
lists together so she's a dear friend of
our show and she just revealed one of
her favorite hobbies people reports that
dakota says in her spare time she loves
to crash weddings what how fun is that i
just rewatched wedding crashers this
weekend too so i'm i was primed for this
um one time she said she was holding up
a bride and groom in a chair
i mean what having aguila i love it and
um they looked down and they were like
oh
whoa what are you doing here
um dakota you little minx i love this
about you all your layers come crash our
show or a wedding anytime soon
have you ever crashed anything rossi i
would never crash a wedding in my life
especially since i'm planning one now
all i'm thinking myself is like that's
three shrimp that's three shrimp right
we plan ahead this is what's happening
on tiktok it's exactly what you think it
is apparently you boil potato chips
out of the bag and then mash them into a
paste
and then you add in milk butter or cream
and salt and pepper to taste i think it
sounds like a goblin oh yeah right yeah
um okay so sorry i'm salivating um
so this is remember like idaho spuds and
potato buds oh my god the boxed potato i
didn't know mashed potatoes came from an
actual potato until i was like 20. i
thought this was out of the box so this
feels like kind of a i don't know some
version of that yeah is that it i want
it to be really good right well one two
three okay okay ready
right here
oh
yeah yeah i don't like it
no we love it
we get mad when we like it because then
it's like oh no now it's going to be a
thing yum oh this sucks okay
no
now this is going to haunt my dream
do you all practice the five second rule
raise of hands
um okay martha stewart.com reports that
scientists have actually tested the
five-second rule in a
lab they dropped a piece of bologna well
that's just like that's gross all right
it's like tape yeah right i'm just gonna
pick something
totally taped um and a piece of dry
bread on a surface with oh salmonella on
it
and they let it sit for five seconds 30
seconds and then a full minute and the
results are in
regardless of how long it sat there the
food was very definitely contaminated oh
man
even after just five seconds that
bologna was salmonella city i know
oh
god
well i mean oh man
i feel like there are two types of five
second rules in the world there's like
five second rule around people and
you're like no i'm not gonna
and then there's the five second rule at
home where you're like that's been there
for like i don't know a few minutes i
actually one time just found a jelly
bean
and i ate it this story um really spoke
to me the baltimore museum of art just
opened a new exhibit curated by their
own security guards
the week my favorite magazine reports
the exhibit is called guarding the art
and it's up through july so the museum
has 17 of their security guards that
obviously are in the you know building
all day every day to select works from
the collection that were important and
meaningful to the security guards guard
ben bjork picked a chair made out of
pencils by artist jeremy aldean because
ben says he spends a lot of the day
thinking about sitting down
well yeah all right um
ross
the fact that they got to choose to
curate a show based on what they love
just made me feel like it was so
accessible and so doable i thought no
that's a show i want to go see so well
done to this museum
[Music]
you